the hierarchy of power
in the dc universe is about to change
dc fandom hall of heroes august 22nd
only at dc fandom.com
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wanter where we talk about all things
marvel
and dc and to our surprise we just got
a teaser for black adam from none other
than
the rock himself now this is happening
right before we're actually going to get
the official reveal
of the rock as black adam this is
happening tomorrow at dc's fandom
tomorrow at dc fandom we're going to be
getting a ton of new
exclusive showings of wonder woman 1984
the batman the snyder cut of the justice
league the suicide squad and of course
black adam and it's going to be awesome
as you heard the rock say
the hierarchy of power in the dc
universe is about to change
and they kind of gave us a little teaser
of the official
logo we see parts of it in here but they
didn't reveal it yet that's coming
tomorrow now be sure to subscribe to my
other channel cosmic culture we'll be
covering dc fandom
all day literally everything you need to
know about your favorite dc films and
projects coming up will cover
on cosmic culture tomorrow so head over
there subscribe and click the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any news let me know what you think
about this tiny little teaser from the
rock himself
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel or dc news as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you